Hi,
I'm currently going through a hard time
as a first time mum was a nine month
old.
I feel depressed and anxious
and I'm highly neurotic.
Invalid title.
Can you suggest anything
to help me be a better mom?
Well,
you know,
lots of people have a hard time with,
they're nine months old.
I guess the first question would be,
are you getting enough sleep?
Do you have enough help?
Are you eating enough?
Especially in the morning,
you know,
and you're going to feel highly neurotic
and volatile to some degree because
while you've been through
quite a physiological trauma
and it's very demanding
to have a newborn baby,
so the,
the best thing I could say,
not knowing you,
is to make sure that you
have people around that you
can talk to about your baby
and that you can and that you can take a
break when you need to and have someone
spell you.
I mean that's often the role that a
husband plays in the first year of,
of a baby's life is that he can,
he's supposed to watch the mother to make
sure that she doesn't get overwhelmed
by the demands of the baby.
And so I would hope that you're able to
ask for support when you need it and not
to be afraid of asking for support,
especially to get arrest and to get
something to eat because that's really
important,
especially in the morning.
Um,
other than that,
I can't tell you anything really specific,
unfortunately,
given that I don't know anything
about the specifics of your situation.
Um,
if it gets out of hand,
you know,
you should go.
The other thing I should say
is if it gets out of hand,
you should go speak with your,
with your doctor,
with a professional,
because you might have
postpartum depression.
There's some dispute about whether that
exists and as an independent diagnostic
entity.
But you can certainly be
physiologically stressed.
And if you have a
predisposition to depression,
then that kind of physiological stress
and sleep disruption can bring it on.
So I would say if it
really gets out of hand,
don't hesitate to go talk
to someone professional.
You know?
It did.
It's,
it may be necessary to do that because
you don't want to fall too far down the
hole and that's for sure.